in other videos when we talked about the
various chinese empires we talk about
the seong dynasty in particular as a
time of significant technological
innovation
and here are just some of the examples
that we talk about most notably gun
powder movable block print you have
block printing emerge during the tang
dynasty but during
during the song dynasty it gets
perfected and you and it becomes more
efficient with movable block print you
have the compass being perfected
especially for naval use the boats being
perfected you see this reinvigoration
really the high point of the chinese
civil service you see the emergence of
neo-confucianism
but one question is well what allowed
all of this innovation to take place and
also what allowed for the stability of
the song dynasty when you look at it on
the timeline like this that's covering
over 2000 years it might not look that
long but when you actually think about
it this is over 300 years of dynastic
rule by one dynasty now it is split in
the middle between the northern song and
the southern song that happens in
1127 and we'll talk about that in a
little bit but for the most part it is a
very prosperous time for china the
population actually grows from roughly
50 million people during the tang
dynasty to it is estimated 100 million
people by the northern song dynasty and
eventually keeps growing by the so that
by the time we get to the ming dynasty
we have a population of about 200
million people so what are the things
that allows for that population
explosion really well what one thing you
can imagine is food is very important
and it's during this time period that
the song dynasty is able to leverage a
more robust rice seed from southeast
asia that allows it to feed many many
more people and so this obviously allows
the population growth but any time
you're able to feed people and there's
more prosperity you're going to have a
more stable empire
now another major input into prosperity
and the stability of empires is the
notion of trade
and china had always many river systems
which helped facilitate agriculture and
trade but as you get into the sway
dynasty right over here
you have the completion of the grand
canal which is even today the largest
man-made
canal it stretches from beijing to
hangzhou and actually goes beyond that
and has other tributaries and that
connected with the existing river
systems allowed for a lot of trade to
happen especially as we get into the
tang and the song dynasties now the song
dynasty in particular you have the pound
lock being invented which allows for
easier travel across waterways when you
have a change in the level of water and
the pound lock is still the standard
technology used in canals throughout the
world
you also have the first use
of paper money this is a big deal we use
paper money today our ability to have
transactions in our society are not
dependent on our ability to mine for
gold or silver or copper and one of the
things that allowed for paper money to
even be used was this notion of block
printing and block printing with movable
type in particular once again a song
dynasty innovation now as i mentioned as
we get into 11 27 you have conquerors
from the north in particular the jinn
who are able to conquer northern china
they caused the song to move their
capital from kaifeng in the north to
hangzhou in the south here you see
hungzhou is the major southern terminal
of the grand canal and even though the
northern song had to move and
essentially become the southern song
dynasty you continue to have that
prosperity for roughly another 150 years
and once again this comes from this
meritocracy from the civil service
system this abundance of food the
stability from having the dynastic rule
the trade the money all of these
technological advances which make the
song dynasty one of the notable periods
of chinese history